this video is sponsored by blinkist use
the link in the description and you'll
receive one free week and 25 off an
annual premium membership
Molly was born completely blind she has
never seen a color a shape an object
anything she navigates and understands
the world primarily through touch and
sound in order to distinguish the object
she encounters she runs her hands across
their surfaces
Molly is also very superstitious for
good luck she always carries with her
her lucky marble and lucky dye depending
on the situation she often takes one of
them out and rubs it in her hand she can
distinguish between the dye and the
marble by feeling and Discerning the
dye's angular edges and pointed Corners
versus the marbles round smooth surface
at 18 years old Molly undergoes cataract
removal surgery and an intraocular lens
implant her blindness is effectively
cured
Molly awakes from the surgery and for
the first time in her life she sees the
world around her all the colors and
shapes and objects previously known to
her only by touch and language
on the table next to the hospital bed
are her lucky marble and lucky die in
this moment she wants to hold her lucky
marble she looks at both items on the
table before touching them can she tell
which is which can she tell the marble
from the die having only touched them
but never seen them
this question is what is known as
molineux problem originally formulated
by philosopher William molyneux in 1688
intuitively it might seem obvious to
assume that Molly will be able to
connect the smoothness she's touched in
the past to the rounded appearance of
the spherical marble and the pointedness
she's felt to the angular appearance of
the cubic die but without any prior
visual experience without any reference
points for what smoothness or pointiness
or anything looks like how would she be
able to make these connections
for hundreds of years versions of this
thought experiment have divided
philosophers empiricists believing
someone in the situation would not be
able to identify the objects because
knowledge comes only or primarily from
first-hand sense experiences which in
this case have not yet been had
rationalists believe that the person
would be able to identify the objects
because knowledge chiefly comes from our
ability to reason and the connections
will be able to be deduced through one's
rational faculties
nowadays though modern science allows
for the possibility of this thought
experiment to not just be debated over
but actually tested
in 2011 MIT professors Richard held and
Dr Pawan singha conducted an experiment
in which a group of children and
teenagers who were born blind received
cataract removal surgery curing their
blindness
just following their surgery the
participants were then presented with
lego-like blocks one collection of
blocks was placed visibly on a table and
another identical collection was placed
hidden from view under the table only
perceivable by touch when the
participants were asked to match objects
they had felt with objects seen the
results were essentially equivalent to
chance with 58 accuracy in other words
Molly would not dependably be able to
identify the marble or the dye the
experiment concluded that the
empiricists were right the primary tool
we have to get the outside world inside
her head and to knowledge and
understanding is our senses not our
reason
and then this study is not without
critiques though and some argue that
since there is variability and other
factors involved with things like the
surgery's recovery process as well as
the duration of time participants were
tested after it the problem is still
somewhat inconclusive however regardless
molineux problem points to a broader
problem our first unanswerable
philosophical question how do we know
that what we are perceiving is accurate
if we come to understand the world not
primarily through reason but through our
sense experiences how accurate are our
perceptions and understandings if our
senses are limited and often unreliable
most of us assume that what we are
encountering outside of our head is
relatively consistent with how it seems
inside but how do we know and can we
ever know for sure
the term qualia refers to the internal
subjective qualitative properties of
experiences this includes things like
color taste and feelings pain love
sharpness smoothness and so on and so
whether or not what we are perceiving is
accurate to the world in and of itself
depends largely on whether or not qualia
or our subjective experiences are
intrinsic properties of the world or
merely a product of the mind or some
combination
even if we can use tools to measure test
and enhance our insights about the
physical world the last stop for
everything is still the mind we're
always left with and limited by the
cognitive and perceptual Frameworks in
built in the mind
since we can never experience anything
outside of the Mind including the Mind
itself we can never know what anything
is actually like outside of it
this is often referred to as the
egocentric predicament this leads us to
the next seemingly unanswerable
philosophical question how do we know
that what we are perceiving is the same
as other people of course since we can
never experience anything outside of our
mind we can also never enter into
another person's to know what things are
like for them
not only can we not know if the
experience of blue is entirely unique to
the human mind but we also can't know if
the specific blue we personally
experience is unique to our mind alone
or at least as different from what is
experienced in some portion of other
Minds since we can communicate
relatively successfully about events and
objects in the world we can know that
differences amongst objects and events
outside our mind are generally
proportionally consistent with
differences experienced inside our mind
but just because we refer to the
differences with the same terms does not
mean that the differences are
experienced as the same thing perhaps
what you see as green looks like blue in
your friend's mind and vice versa but
you just associate the same words with
the same differences because all qualia
are housed in the conscious private mind
we can never objectively perceive
measure or Define them without using
tools or terminology that don't also
fall victim to the same problem
this leads us to the next unanswerable
question
how do we know that anything or anyone
exists outside our mind at all
if you can never get out of your mind
and experience anything outside of it
and you can never enter the mind of
anyone else how can you know for sure
that anything or anyone exists outside
of your mind
we reasonably assume that since the
world interface is back with us objects
and people respond to our actions people
talk and act like they feel and think
things and so on that all of these
things are real independent things
outside of our mind but how can you know
for sure that those people and things
aren't merely creations of your mind you
do this every night when you dream
without question
can you prove right now that you are not
on some sort of spaceship hurtling
through the cosmos a member of an
advanced species that has sent itself
off on a long journey to avoid a
catastrophe happening on its host Planet
the only way to make the duration of the
journey endurable was to be placed in a
stasis tube with wires plugged into your
brain temporarily clearing all memories
and actively stimulating your brain's
nerve impulses throughout the trip in
order to create a lifetime worth of
experiences until arriving somewhere
else and remembering it was all a
simulated reality
of course odds are arguably very
unlikely that this or anything similar
is the case but the point is the odds
are not zero and you simply cannot know
for sure
although you can never know for sure
about anything that exists outside your
mind the one thing you can know for sure
is that you exist somewhere and
something as philosopher Rene Descartes
pointed out if you can think and doubt
you must exist
but then where did you come from
even if what you perceive isn't real
there still seemingly needs to be
something other than yourself that
created you and simulates causes or
implants what you perceive
if you in some form exist you must
either be the creator of yourself or
something else must have created you
if we assume the more likely and normal
belief that other things and other
people do exist and you are created by
other people then those who created you
must have also been created by something
or someone else and whoever created them
again must have been created by someone
or something else so on and so forth all
the way back add infinitum to the
beginning of humanity the beginning of
Life the beginning of Earth and the
beginning of everything
and so no matter the case where did it
all come from if something or someone
created everything who created it or
them if everything came from nothing how
could it have come to being at all
this brings us to our final unanswered
and possibly unanswerable philosophical
question
does God exist
of course God means different things to
different people but in terms of what is
traditionally considered God defined in
all three of the abrahamic religious
texts the Bible the Torah and the Quran
there are quite a few problems
and these religions God is defined as
omniscient omnipotent and omnibenevolent
this means that God is all-knowing aware
of everything that has happened is
happening and will happen all powerful
possessing unlimited power and able to
do anything and all good possessing
maximal morality the problem is that
there are a multitude of paradoxes that
arise from these qualities for example
the classic omnipotence Paradox the
Paradox of the stone which shows that if
God is omnipotent he must be able to
create a stone so large and heavy that
even he can't lift it if he can't create
the stone how can he be omnipotent but
if he cannot lift it how can he be
omnipotent similarly if God knows
everything that will happen then he
knows every choice intervention and
action he will ever make thus he can
never change his mind if he does change
his mind and he's omniscient he must
have known that he was going to change
his mind beforehand and therefore he
wouldn't be changing his mind if he
didn't know he was going to change his
mind he must not be omniscient if he
can't change his mind he must not be
omnipotent lastly there is what is known
as the problem of evil which is defined
as follows if God is all-powerful
all-knowing and all good why does evil
and tragedy and suffering pervade the
world if God is omnipotent he must be
able to prevent evil and suffering if he
is also omniscient he must be able to
know and foresee it and so he either
wants to prevent evil but he is not able
to do so or is not aware of it or he is
aware of it and can do so but does not
want to prevent it in the former he is
not all-powerful or not all-knowing or
both in the latter he is not all good if
one argues that God provides the
individual with free will so as to allow
the individual to choose to follow him
or not would not God's plan and
awareness already include the individual
choosing or not choosing to follow him
for what reason would God cause and
allow individuals to not choose to
follow him or be morally good if it
meant that they would cause evil and
suffering if these instances are rather
some sort of test why would an
all-knowing all-powerful God need to
make people undergo tests involving
horrible evil and suffering if he can
create a flourishing world without the
need for tests involving horrible evil
and suffering he must work in mysterious
sadistic ways of course it could be
possible that God is maximally great but
not all-powerful or he is not omniscient
and is not aware of what's going on or
isn't all good but rather he is morally
fallible and of course God or the
creator of everything or perhaps more
accurately the underlying nature of
everything could be something entirely
different completely beyond our ability
to imagine let alone Define but the
point is the God we have traditionally
defined has its problems and the God we
haven't we don't know of
in truth we cannot yet disprove the
existence of any God any more than we
can prove the one many claim to know
currently the only honest answer is we
don't know
ultimately we can't get out of our minds
to know what the universe is really like
in and of itself we can't enter into
other Minds to know what it is like for
anyone else we can't know if outside our
mind there is anything at all or if it
is real in the way we think and we
cannot dig within our mind to know where
it originally came from
but perhaps the problem is merely our
conception of our mind or more
accurately our conception of ourself we
often view ourselves as a distinct and
separate thing perceiving other things
we see ourselves as being in the mind
and our mind as being in our body but
the body is inescapably in the world and
we are no less dependent on the world
than we are the body all of these things
are simultaneously interlocked and
interdependent thus perhaps in this way
there is really no outside of you you
are merely a fully embedded non-separate
part inescapably attached to the body of
the universe if we view ourselves in
this way there is no accurate or
inaccurate perception no dichotomy
between the world as it is and the world
as you experience it No Beginning No End
no outside no inside no separate no
other there is just a single unified
whole of everything everything equally
true Everything equally proportional
eternally dancing the dance of
everything to the tune of nothing
to doubt the existence of anything
outside of you is perhaps entirely
reasonable because in this sense you are
everything else and everything else is
you
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist our
sense of self can be disorienting it is
partly our anchor to reality and partly
our vessel of alienation from everything
the books being You by Daniel Seth the
biological Mind by Alan jazanov and the
man who wasn't there by Anil anatha
Swami provide highly unique and engaging
insights into modern understandings of
this topic exploring the brain the mind
and the self and asking what it means to
be you in the world and how you came to
be a you in the world using the app
blinkist you can learn from all of these
books and More in Just Around 15 minutes
each by condensing over 5 500 of the
best non-fiction books and podcasts
across 27 different categories into
thoughtfully organized and eloquently
written 15-minute text and audio
explainers that can be accessed even
while offline blinkist allows you to
discover New Perspectives learn about
thought-provoking ideas and derive
useful information about just about any
subject whenever and wherever you are if
you enjoy sharing your interests and
discoveries with a friend or partner
blinkist's feature blinkist connect also
allows premium users to share their
account with another a person for the
same price essentially providing two
memberships for the price of one
connected accounts can easily share
their favorite blinks and short casts
with each other while also being able to
control which titles are kept private if
you're interested in further developing
enhancing and supplementing your reading
habit use the link in the description
and you'll receive one free week of
unlimited access to blinkist as well as
25 off an annual premium membership the
free 7-Day trial can be canceled at any
time within the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed
considering and trying to answer
difficult philosophical questions
consider checking out my guided writing
journal which I've filled with these
kinds of questions you can also find the
link to it in the description below
foreign
[Music]